[Musique]
quelle est la distance idéale entre sa
maison et un espace vert 300 m
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
recommande que tout le monde est accès à
un espace vert à moins de 300 mètres de
chez soi accessible en 5 minutes de
marche environ la nature la forêt les
arbres ont de nombreux effets positifs
sur la santé physique il favorise
l'activité sportive en ville diminue la
mortalité associée aux maladies
cardiovasculaires et respiratoires les
espaces verts sont aussi bénéfiques pour
la santé mentale il diminue le stress
les symptômes de dépression et améliore
l'humeur on sait depuis les années 80
qu'un patient hospitalisé avec vue sur
des arbres guérira plus vite et avec
moins de médicaments et de complications
qu'un patient qui a vu sur un mur les
arbres sont aussi efficaces contre la
pollution sonore et pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air en diminuant la
température de plusieurs degrés et en
créant des zones d'ombre il permet de
lutter contre les îlots de chaleur un
arbre proche d'une maison réduit les
besoins en climatisation de 30% plantez
un arbre n'est donc pas une dépense mais
un bel investissement durable